[Musique]
allez de l'elysée harmonie d'hier
harmonie d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ceci n'est pas exactement une pièce en
ce sens qu'il n'y a pas de maps n'est
d'ailleurs pas complètement terminée
disons que c'est un lieu devant lequel
on passe est un lieu si colorée si
extraordinaire qu'on soit en effet un
effet choc une espèce de mise en
position l'image de la vie
combien de déchets chlorés par
transparence
juxtaposition qui le regarde
les tableaux elle même composée
d'environ 900 couleurs différentes
réalités en rade un plain pied dans les
tableaux d'habitude on regarde le
tableau est encadré par un cadre qui
comme à fenêtre qu'elle est sûre ça se
passe dehors du goût moi j'imagine est
depuis qu'eric j'étais enfin j'imagine
est toujours de vivre d'un tableau dans
cette expérience on rende un tableau
dont romain d'un tableau malgré
l'exiguïté de la place elle est infini
comme grandir parce qu' à chaque instant
tu es un âne un nouvel visage nouvelle
vision c'est apparaissent nous entrons
maintenant dans la première des trois
autres pièces de la party de l'elysée
réaménagé premières impressions les
lignes courbes domine
deux de ses pièces selon le fumoir sont
tendus de laine beige la troisième le
seul à manger blanche rigueur et
souplesse et elle semble avoir été le
choix du dessinateur il est jeune il
appelle pierre paulin
il s'agissait en l'occurrence
de respecter les lieux
tel qu'il se présentait préalablement
sont des boiseries napoléon iii qui se
trouve d'ailleurs derrière les murs que
l'on peut voir ici
le principe
d'aménagement est constitué comme on
peut le voir de
d'éléments préfabriqués en atelier en
usine selon les cas et juxtaposés ici
sur place prédominance de lignes courbes
pourquoi
prédominance de l'île courbes et bien ma
foi on a lié
les deux points de vue psychologiquement
ça va sembler plus agréable et
techniquement c'était effectivement plus
aisé à réaliser tout au moins dans les
conditions que où cela avait été décidé
vous avez dit psychologiquement il faut
dire que nous sommes dans des lieux qui
sont à la fois des lieux de réception et
des lieux de travail car tout à l'elysée
doit être considérée comme lieu de
travail c'est cela absolument et les
lumières et les appareils d'éclairage
sont tous munis de gradateur de manière
à pouvoir également régler l'intensité
lumineuse comme on le dessine mais ils
sont également mobile on peut évidemment
les rendre directs ou indirects comme
ceux ci le la particularité tout au
moins dans ce salon est que les sièges
sont intégrés à l'architecturé
d'ensemble et que le mur lui-même sert
de dossiers au siège
l'élysée de tradition est célèbre pour
ses lustres dans les salles nouvellement
aménagé il n'y a pas de l'usso bien il
n'y a qu'un lustres et c'est tout le
plafond de la salle à manger qui est
injuste les murs sont en quoi en
l'occurrence il s'agit de polyester les
lustres ce dans quoi ce sont des cannes
de verre des cannes de verre qui sont
suspendus dans des trams si vous voulez
les parties de ces trames qui ne sont
pas occupées par des cannes de verre
sont remplies par des billes de verre
c'est à dire que ça crée une sorte de
plafond tout enlever tout animé par
l'ovaire quant aux lumières proprement
dite il s'agit de lampes halogènes
appelé en général n'en période et elles
sont réfléchies par un grand plafond en
aluminium
anodisé qui renvoie une lumière
légèrement rosée de manière à rectifier
l'aspect un peu froid du verre comme
dans les autres salons des gradateurs ou
aurait un star permettent de régler
cette lumière
de table dans cette salle à manger aux
lignes courbes de table ronde pour un
total de 24 couverts
ce sont des sièges en aluminium coulé
l'habillage de l'aluminium est constitué
d'un revêtement en matière plastique qui
a été utilisé d'ailleurs pour regret tir
l'intérieur des cellules d cabine apollo
et d'hellemmes et voici le seul fauteuil
beige en cuir tourner ici comme dans
l'ensemble de l'elysée réaménagé et
resterez on remarque le goût d'un mètre
d'eau en fait ils sont le président de
la république et madame georges pompidou
la tension est très visible c'est
l'ouverture dans la continuité appliquée
aux choses de exemple d'ouverture parmi
les oeuvres modernes actuellement
présenté une sculpture abstraite de
harpe à droite sur votre écran des
peintures également abstraite du couple
karabagh delaunay vasarely des oeuvres
de matisse
et des peintures figuratives ici roger
de la freiner et ici albert marque mais
la continuité c'est également à partir
de cette nature d'oudry les trois salons
de tradition dans leur et ameublement
est constitué en fait par un magistral
regroupement d'un admirable ensemble
mobilier du xviiie siècle jusqu'à leur
dispersion la plupart des maps ou
signées georges jacobs qui fut le
premier d'une célèbre lignée de grands
ébénistes france
les trois salons ainsi restitué son le
salon des ambassadeurs le salon des
portraits le salon de l'émission
du détail ou de l'ensemble
du travail des event des siècles passés
ou du travail des restaurateurs
d'aujourd'hui on ne sait ce qu'on admire
le plus en ce palais de l'elysée
[Musique]
m
en bref sans qu'il y ait deux
conclusions le mobilier national a
maintenant donner le ton
si depuis peut-être une visite du
président de la république en 1969 et
puis il y à l'opinion publique eh bien
nous l'avons vu en début d'émission
l'opinion publique accepte les formes
modernes avec une certaine réticence et
peut-être que le ton est donné là aussi
par l'elysée cette ouverture à l'art de
notre temps dans le respect un certain
amour pour la tradition ce qu'elle
admire
[Musique]